now these people are of course incapable
of shame and so um all of the
embarrassment was felt secondhand on
friday when espn paused during its
coverage of the women's ncaa basketball
tournament to have a moment of silence
in protests of the florida legislation
which lying opponents have dishonestly
dubbed the don't say gay bill the stunt
sparked for one thing a philosophical
debate among some people which is that
you know if espn anchors stage a protest
during women's basketball coverage and
nobody is watching to notice did it
really happen
we'll leave that discussion for another
time for now here is uh one anchor
explaining the demonstration watch
legislation happening in florida and
across other states as well that are
targeting our lgbtqi plus communities
many of our colleagues here at espn have
planned and organized a walkout that
will be happening at 3 pm eastern today
and to be honest with you we thought we
were going to come here today and really
celebrate a sport that has meant so much
and done so much including for so many
in the lgbtqia plus communities but we
understand the gravity of this
legislation and also how it is affecting
so many families across this country and
because of that our ally ship is going
to take a front seat and with that we're
going to pause in solidarity
wow
i mean
i can't decide what's more brave the
blatant lies the phrase our ally ship
will take a front seat or the moment of
silence on a broadcast with zero viewers
it's hard to say but she wasn't alone
the announcers on the court also joined
in let's listen to that
our
lgbtqia plus teammates at disney ask for
our solidarity and support including our
company's support in opposition to the
parental rights and education bill in
the state of florida and similar
legislation across the united states and
a threat to any
human rights is a threat to all human
rights and at this time courtney and i
we're going to take a pause from our
broadcast to show our love and support
for our friends our families and our
colleagues
[Music]
needless to say of course none of these
people have read the bill or know what's
in it or have any idea what's going on
now you don't actually see the whole
moment of silence there but trust me
it's uh it it was inspirational
speaking of inspiring disney on the same
day announced that in further protests
of the florida legislation that forbids
teachers from talking to six-year-olds
about their sexuality that's the thing
that's a threat to human rights is if we
don't allow teachers to talk to
six-year-olds about their sexuality then
human rights are threatened because what
because six-year-olds have a human right
to be sexually indoctrinated by their
creepy pervert teachers or is it that
the creepy part of teachers have a human
right to indoctrinate kids yeah i think
that's probably what it is as far as
they're concerned but anyway disney
announced that they would be releasing a
film um where two lesbian cartoon
characters make out
and this again is is you know another
inspiring thing that they're doing uh
because of the bill this is from the
daily wire says pixar has reportedly
decided to reinstate a same-sex kiss in
the upcoming animated children's film
light year in response to florida's
so-called don't say gay bill and the
walt disney company's leadership
response to it a source close to the
production said the next feature film
from the studio about the real life
story of how the famed toy story
character buzz lightyear came to be
will reportedly include a kiss between
two female characters reported variety
in a piece published friday one of the
characters is reportedly a significant
female role by the name of hawthorne
um
so by the way this is i mean just to
clarify this is a cartoon
about the origin story
of the film character
that the buzz lightyear toy
is based on
that's the the origin story
a fake origin story
of a fake character from a fake movie
that a fake toy
was was based on if you're wondering
whether major hollywood studios are
utterly and completely out of ideas
i think i should probably answer it for
you
i mean no self-respect in person should
have ever even been considering buying
tickets for this 100 minute toy
commercial to begin with but especially
not now
now that it's being used not only as a
vehicle to sell disney merchandise which
is the main reason why any disney movie
exists but also as a forum to protest
the prohibition of childhood
sexualization
and yet we see in this move by disney
and the demonstrations on espn and all
the other theatrics from the left
surrounding this bill
a certain not so subtle hint of
desperation
because they're panicked frenzied
they can see the cultural tide turning
slightly and they're terrified you know
with prices skyrocketing inflation gas
prices going up we all need to find ways
to save money every single day and
there's a lot of money that we're all
wasting every day without even noticing
it whether you're in the market for a
basic kitchen appliance or a luxury
upgrade to your old tv deal dash will
allow you to get the best deals on
whatever you're looking for dealdash
partners with brands of all sizes
wholesalers and inventory liquidators
when these brands are stuck with excess
inventory they can't sell dealdash helps
out by buying these excess lots and can
pass on big savings to its customers on
brand new high quality products deal
dash has hundreds of auctions daily on
brand new items ranging from tvs and
laptops to tools and kitchenware and
even cars with guaranteed free shipping
ipads have sold for 33 dollars and 60
cents brand new cars have sold for less
than a thousand bucks in addition in
order to keep the prices low dash
charges a small fee to place a bid you
can always buy the product at the buy it
now price to get the credits back that
you used in the auction and reuse them
in later auctions as well all auctions
start at zero dollars and you have a
90-day money-back guarantee on your
first bid pack purchase don't be made a
victim to today's inflation get all the
new products you desire without price
hikes a deal dash today use the promo
code walsh for an additional 10 free
bids when making your first bid pack
purchase and start bidding today the
leah thomas charade at the ncaa women's
swimming championships last week
has become its own sort of watershed
moment no pun intended there's a
backlash against the trans agenda right
now unlike anything we've seen to this
point in our culture and it hasn't
abated even after thomas lost his final
races over the weekend clearly throwing
the competition intentionally so the
gender id logs could point to it and say
see it's not so unfair after all
i mean he he won handily in this it was
a 500 meter race and then uh the couple
races he did on saturday he he lost he
came in sixth place or something
um wasn't even competitive so pretty
clear that he lost on purpose
but that has done little to stem the
tide of outrage nor should it on sunday
an ncaa uh swimmer by the name of rika
giorgi
wrote a letter to the ncaa protesting
their decision to let a male compete now
she's the first female swimmer to
formally and publicly complain with her
name attached
bold move brave move necessary move
and i admire her for it
now on the other hand i
you know i don't think it's splitting
hairs to point out that
when i read this letter
um
she refers to leah thomas as she
multiple times
and also talks about how much she
respects leah thomas and all those
things and leah thomas is is pursuing
his dreams or rather her dreams
and so on and so forth now this doesn't
totally negate the impact of the letter
but it does diminish it slightly sadly
because by calling thomas she
it concedes the underlying claim that
thomas is making i mean either thomas is
a she
or not and he's not
and since he's not he doesn't belong in
the women's league
but if he was a she then there'd be no
reason to complain
and trying to keep him out or her out in
that case would indeed be unfair and
wrong
i mean literally the the only argument
against thomas's participation and it's
the only argument we need
is that he is a he that's the whole
argument there is nothing else that's
all there is to say he's a he
by calling he she you undercut yourself
accidentally conceding the very point
you're supposed to be arguing against
so the letter is a good start
um definitely again i don't mean to
detract from the bravery it took to
write it and it does take bravery
but
we need to go a lot farther
i mean this was this this is this is a a
good start a good step
we need to go farther than that
and we need to be arguing against
all of this on a on a fundamental level
so here was another good sign the
swimming finals was also the scene of a
confrontation between activist kelly j
keane
and a man who now identifies as a trans
woman after 50 years as a man
keane was trying to explain to this guy
why she is not comfortable with him
using the female restroom and here's how
that exchange went
hang on on the basis of the comfort and
dignity of girls and women i'm asking
you and telling you please do not lose
women's faces it makes them feel
uncomfortable my girls and the other
women i am with
are very comfortable with being right
well fortunately i'm not your daughter
and my daughter is also not your
daughter that's right and she would
still
she would feel
very uncomfortable
right now you
do not use
and i'm female
uncomfortable it makes women and girls
as a mother i am very you're not you'll
never birth your children you're not a
mother dawn
you javascript this guy
as a mother
this is a 50 year old dude who after 50
years as a dude decided to put on a wig
and call himself a woman that's it
one day wakes up puts a wig on mama i'm
a mother having skipped all of the most
difficult aspects of motherhood he now
wants to claim the title for himself
except you ran into at least one woman
who won't go along with it doesn't want
the women's restroom to turn into a
masquerade ball or a costume party for
this guy's sake
what comes across most of all in the
conversation between the two
is as i pointed too many times the
overwhelming suffocating narcissism of
the trans person in this exchange
he simply doesn't care how anyone else
feels and
you know what anyone else wants he takes
whatever he wants for himself without
any concern for anybody around him
he claims the bathrooms of women he
claims their very identities
tries to make it all his own somewhat
paradoxically though uh while he covets
womanhood he also very clearly has
incredible contempt for the women
themselves
he hates women
but yet wants to be them
and he along with all the all the other
gender ideologues have been running
roughshod over the culture for years
taking whatever they want with no
resistance
that finally seems to be changing
slightly
now don't get me wrong i'm not declaring
victory we're a very long way off from
anything that can be considered a
cultural victory on this front or any
other front because victory if it comes
is years down the line generations away
probably it took generations to lose the
culture will take generations to get it
back
but recently we have seen some movement
in the right direction
we're seeing some of that here
baby steps towards sanity and moral
decency
now these advances could easily stall if
we succeed in say getting men out of
women's sports and then decide that
that's good enough call ourselves the
winner go back to ignoring the issue i
could see that happening
or if we all you know
go with the line that some conservatives
have adopted claiming that you know we
have no problem with the left gender
theories in general we just care about
fairness and sports or privacy in the
bathroom
or whatever as if that's the fundamental
issue which it isn't
what we have to remain firm on
is that we are we have a problem with
the very concept
you know the very con the guy there in
the wig the very concept
that he could be a woman because he says
he is that's that is what we are taking
issue with that's what we're arguing
against
that's what we're fighting
it's not just this or that particular
thing that that guy wants to do
but it's the very claim that he is
making about himself
there are still a lot of people on the
right who are
very cautious about that very afraid
and so you see this even now you see you
see plenty of people
you know even conservatives who who for
the first time are really speaking out
about some of this stuff they're saying
oh i don't have any problem with
transgenderism it's just it's just
women's sports that i care about
now we adopt that we make that our line
that's a mistake and we lose
meanwhile
you know the left will only become more
desperate more enraged
try to push even further
as we're seeing down in florida they
will they will double down and triple
down then double down on their triple
down again as they've done in florida
the battle only gets more vicious from
here but i think we're finally moving
ever so slightly
in the right direction
[Music]